it's like it has a die there is no spoon
[Music]
hello Internet
welcome to film theory where the spoon
doesn't Bend it's only you last time we
talked about the matrix we covered the
idea that the one wasn't Keanu Reeves
what was in fact an unwitting Agent
Smith Oh Rhonda for the win and I was
able to convince a lot of you even read
it was pretty darn positive with that
episode for once you guys liked one of
my theories still not my voice though
anyway the biggest objection I heard was
that neo had to be the one since his
powers not only exists within the matrix
but also outside of it in the real world
aboard the good ship Nebuchadnezzar
remember that time when he used some
sort of telekinesis or a technopath e to
stop control and destroy the machine
droids in the real world or how he was
still able to see the aura of Smith in
the machines after being blinded in
revolutions No
well trust me those things happen it's
easy to forget them amidst machine baby
key makers and Merovingians whatsits but
here's the kicker I bet if he tried hard
enough neo would be able to do so so
much more in the real world with his
powers and it's not because he's the one
oh no neo is able to have these
superpowers because he's still in the
matrix
they all are Morpheus Trinity
enthusiastic rave dancer everything were
shown in these movies from Zion to the
city to the simulations aboard
Nebuchadnezzar are different tears
within a grand complex multi-layered
matrix like Inception but with more
trench coats and fewer
ready to have your eyes opened and see
the truth let's start by paying a visit
to the architects chamber from the
Matrix Reloaded now this scene is
awesome with all the screens showing all
the different outcomes and iterations of
Neos conversation here but while you're
trying to focus on what exactly the
architect was saying deciphering the
string of air goes and consequently you
probably overlooked this in the
architect's long and confusing monologue
he states that the first matrix failed
because it was built as a utopia it was
too perfect humans wouldn't accept it as
a reality the second Matrix failed
because humans need a choice and so as
long as humans were offered a choice
even one felt and an unconscious level
99% would accept the matrix living in
the virtual world the remaining 1% would
choose the other option becoming a free
mind destined to become part of a human
resistance based in Zion in his speech
he says this you are the eventualities
of an anomaly which despite my sincerest
efforts I have been unable to eliminate
from what is otherwise a harmony of
mathematical precision but if the one is
truly the only imperfection in a
mathematically perfect system that would
mean he's already found a solution for
human free will for the remaining 1% of
people who refuse to accept the matrix
and what was that solution well he did
it by offering them a choice the option
of Zion the quote-unquote real world a
simulated quest to escape being enslaved
by the machines he's already admitted to
creating imperfect worlds for humans to
accept the matrix is it really so hard
to believe that he would create a
simulated struggle as another tier
within the matrix to account for those
humans who reject a digital world it may
seem like overthinking at first but it
actually explains a lot of logical
errors from the franchise
first off let's look at the hilariously
convoluted plot of the machines Futurama
nailed this one on the head don't be
ridiculous their bodies are being used
to generate electricity the idea came
from an old movie called The Matrix but
but wouldn't almost anything make a
better battery than a human body like a
potato or a battery so we're supposed to
believe that the machines keep growing
and harvesting humans for use as
makeshift batteries powering their
vast artificial empire but the sad truth
is that just doesn't stack up with
science the amount of energy produced by
literally billions of humans would be
pocket change compared to other sources
of power available to the machines wind
geothermal really anything plus no
matter how much energy they produced it
would take more energy than that to keep
them alive it makes much more sense to
use this set up of humans they got going
as something like a neural network for
extra processing or computing power
which as it turns out fun fact was
actually the Wachowskis original idea
the suits at Warner Brothers thought
that the human network concept would be
too confusing to an audience who had
only recently been exposed to computers
at a massive scale
and as a result forced the Wachowskis to
change it in the last minute what we as
audiences were left with was a huge
scientific hole or a really compelling
scenario to keep the people who reject
the matrix occupied freeing their fellow
pod people speaking of the people who
reject the matrix we learn from the
architect that the five predecessors to
neo have supposedly freed a new set of
humans and led to the creation of a new
Zion under the supervision of the
machines after which you will be
required to select from the matrix 23
individual 16 female 7 male to rebuild
Zion I'm liking those odds
the dreams of repopulating the world
aside why would the machines have
difficulty finding and gaining access to
Zion when they're the ones who are
allowing it to happen that are yet why
would they allow Zion to exist in the
first place if they knew the rebels were
going to cause so much trouble for them
in the long run I mean the architect
even admits they've destroyed it five
times before but rest assured
this will be the sixth time we have
destroyed it and we have become
exceedingly efficient and added what a
waste of time really though it all adds
up due to the human need for freewill
some humans will inevitably choose to
reject the matrix when they do they wake
up and enter what they believe to be the
real world where they're all led by a
false Shepherd in the one in a war that
is ironically meant only to pacify them
to stop them from looking just a bit
further and seeing that the real world
this real world is yet another layer in
the illusion created by the matrix the
architect has successfully designed a
system where 1% reject the matrix but
still exist within the matrix
I mean seriously why would neo have
telekinetic powers in the real world the
one is a superhero within the matrix the
prophecies though say nothing about him
also having powers outside of the matrix
in fact there are a ton of absurd
interactions between the digital world
and the one we're led to believe is the
physical one that make no sense unless
the real world is also a part of the
matrix now some of it makes sense like
having the jack in the back of your head
ripped out while your consciousness is
within the matrix being fatal all right
having your mind more or less separated
from your body seems like a pretty sure
fire way to die and I can even by dying
within the matrix killing you in the
real world you know how they say if you
die in a dream you die in real life even
though that's not actually backed by
science it could be written off as some
sort of super intense placebo effect
where the power of suggestion in the
matrix is so strong the brain reacts in
violent ways and shuts down it is a
science fiction action film after all so
we're gonna have to suspend our
disbelief a little bit but when we go a
little further down the rabbit hole the
explanations start to get a lot tougher
for example injuries within the matrix
or other similar simulations are somehow
able to adversely affect the physical
well-being of people's bodies in the
real world and I'm not just talking
about moving and shaking while they're
avatars and the matrix are fighting I
twitch in my sleep all the time that's
perfectly normal I assume no these
injuries draw blood from their real
but the neural link into the matrix is
only into the brain or spinal cord it
shouldn't be affecting blood vessels but
it's even weirder when the reverse
happens like when neo brings Trinity
back from the dead by literally reaching
into her chest and restarting her heart
all from within the matrix he didn't
take a defibrillator to her physical
chest to electrically restart her
heartbeats he touched her digital avatar
made up of code and somehow got her
physical IRL heart to pump again through
a link into her brain and this time we
can't pin it on the power of suggestion
or a placebo effect because her brain is
literally dead she can't be suggested to
be healed because placebo effects can't
work if someone's brain is no longer
functioning if reviving someone by
stimulating their brain or spinal cord
was actually feasible you think you'd
see doctors using it on a more regular
basis right the short answer is quite
frankly it doesn't make sense unless the
quote-unquote real world was also just a
bunch of code it speaking of problems
with jacking in in the third movie Neal
finds himself in the train station limbo
area without being jacked in at all but
that doesn't make any sense from the
movies logic no matter who you think the
one is whether it's neo jumping into the
matrix or Agent Smith jumping out to
transition always needs to happen
through one of those neural Jack's we
also see the kid in Matrix Reloaded and
in the Animatrix Dan Davis pull
themselves out of the matrix by sheer
force of will this would seem to be a
job for cinemasins except the sins can
be explained if the real world and Zion
are just constructs of the machines but
enough talk about logical errors
let's talk cutlery the spoon in the
first movie neo meets a boy who begins
to teach him a bit about the nature of
the matrix saying do not try and bend
the spoon instead early try to realize
the truth there is no spoon in saying
this the boy teaches neo that the spoon
is a symbol that it doesn't actually
exist but instead is a bunch of code
that neo perceives to be
spoon by changing his perception and
seeing the code that makes up the spoon
seeing the truth neo is then able to
bend it and thus was born a decade's
worth of there is no spoon cheat codes
okay interesting idea but then
fast-forward to the second movie when
spoon boy sends neo a present again you
said you'd understand
so spoon boy sends him a spoon in Zion
in the real world first off how but
secondly this moment is never explained
but the Wachowski specifically scripted
that neo be reminded of this symbol in
Zion a symbol of reality being different
from what you see it's a reminder to neo
and to us as the audience said there was
no spoon in the matrix but likewise
there's no spoon here in Zion either you
don't have to take my word the
architect's word or even spoon kids word
for it you can trust everyone's favorite
dirty sweatshirt gang ringleader
Morpheus he's the one who believes this
quest for freedom more than anyone else
he is convinced that neo is the one and
yet the last shot of Morpheus has him in
Zion asking kind of late to be having
second thoughts there buddy seriously
the Wachowski x' didn't put his sudden
lack of faith in there for no good
reason
and beyond that Morpheus is the name for
the Greek god of dreams and his ship the
Nebuchadnezzar is named after a
Babylonian king mentioned in the Bible
who is haunted by bad dreams Morpheus
and his ship are symbols of dreams
illusions and when the franchise starts
we would assume that the dreams his name
is a reference to is the matrix itself
an artificial reality but as the
franchise goes on and we peel back the
layers of strange physics convoluted
speeches and spoons it starts to become
apparent that the illusion isn't just
the matrix it's the real world
another fabrication created by the
machines by including this line of is
this real as humanity finally wins and
Morpheus goals are realized - which
house keys under
mine the victory hinting that he
probably isn't sneaking around the
machines the hunt for the 1z on itself
red or blue huh
take either pill it doesn't matter which
one cuz you'll still be trapped in the
machine wake up theorists there is no
rejecting the matrix but hey that's just
a theory
a film theory and cut we interrupt your
regularly scheduled endcard to bring you
the following nerdy video related
announcement so hey a lot of you came
here because you started out watching
game theory way back in the day like in
April well hold on to your comfy film
Theory watching bark-o-lounger because
we have some serious hanging out to do
for the last month over on the game
theorist Channel we've been live
streaming almost every weekday doing
everything from debating snap can I just
say I just this is this is nuts by the
way like I can't believe that this is
phenom
a Scott for being a part of this
actually thank you to besting your
hardest levels in Mario maker you didn't
see that one where life is shoving an
excessive amount of marshmallows into my
face
[Music]
at the end of the day all about hanging
out with you theorists and now I've
taken the best moments of those live
streams and well-made stuff like this
John Cena
someone asked me to make a John scene
over a lot of people asked me to make
John Cena reference there you go guys
posting those alongside the full
versions of all the craziness you may
have missed so do me a solid click here
to watch my new videos over on GT live
trust me you'll laugh a lot and if you
want a daily dose of gaming goofball
Lurie be sure you subscribe if you like
what you see so take a break from oughte
era film nostalgia and click here to
engage in some ought era game nostalgia
because sometimes you just want to play
games with a friend and then troll them
until they rage quit in front of a live
audience of people so go ahead and click
here to check out the GT live channel
and subscribe I have a fair amount of
confidence you'll be glad you did
[Music]